the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers
from Ridley Scott one of the best
directors working today and also one of
the worst comes the sixth film in the
franchise that makes it official there
are now more bad avian movies than good
ones
muah-muah alien covenant when Ridley
Scott wanted to wank about the meaning
of life or two hours
he gave us Prometheus now he's back with
a good old-fashioned alien flick that
returns to its sci-fi horror roots until
it takes a sharp left turned into the
same wank job territory as the last one
my name is Ozymandias king of canvas no
caught my wife's mighty
save the Android poetry for Blade Runner
damage i want a short haired girl in a
tank top
fighting a xenomorph who kills it by
sucking it is the vacuum of space
now that's the alien I remember in a
franchise full of unforgettable
characters experience a chapter where no
one stands out
except maybe Kenny Powers let's party
and meet the crew of the Covenant
married couples who you'll completely
forget are married until someone says my
wife never heard my wife scared before
behave yourself with my wife with my
wife Styx cheer as this gaggle of idiots
are picked off one by one for their
terrible decisions like aborting their
mission because they heard a John Denver
song
taking a shot not wearing protection on
a foreign planet opening quarantine
rooms with killer aliens in them
shooting at your own fuel tanks having
shower sex in a horror movie slipping in
the same blood puddle twice trusting a
robot who clearly loves aliens and
sticking your face over an alien egg
because that same robot told you to
thankful why would you look in the egg
no maybe these aren't colonists the
earth is a secret program to deport the
world's biggest morons forget the humans
as you spend most of your time in
freshman philosophy class with the
androids Walter and David Michael
Fassbender Jack and Jill sit as both
characters playing to slight variations
on a pretentious literature professor
who wrote Osmond yes by Shelley who are
both so full of themselves they
literally can't keep their fingers off
each other's flute
well this is a long flute sequence
seriously so much flute I did not expect
to associate the Alien franchise with
flute playing but well here we are
might as well enjoy it watch me I'll do
the fingering experience a bad Syfy
script in the hands of a visual genius
as you soak up shot after epic shot
while ignoring how all the tech looks
way more advanced in its prequel and
thrill as CGI lets you finally see the
Xenomorphs move around in full daylight
which just looks wrong click see Batman
at the beach what's next CGI Ripley do
we see when he Weaver joong-dal
techniques so that may be feasible No so
enjoy a film that wants you to ask
questions like who are we and why are we
here but we'll have you asking questions
like why should I care why are critical
plot scenes on YouTube and not in the
movie and wait how many more of these
are they gonna make as this latest
installment gives alien the same
prestige is the Terminator franchise in
that the first two are classics and it's
all been downhill from there
that's the seal Star age data and lore
Ripley believe me she's not almost made
it
he's bound and dumb james franco's STD
and me when i hear six more alien movies
are coming out alien 5 Prometheus - I'll
say it best sci-fi flute work since
Picard
[Music]
hey screen junkies don't miss any honest
trailers be sure to push the bell icon
below to get alerts whenever a new
trailer is available chaos is a ladder
the emoji movie was the most fascinating
and gripping character-driven
masterpiece I have ever seen did
somebody order a sasquatch I know what I
must yabba-dabba-doo I'm sitting in my
mother's basement and a clown outfit
just waiting for my nachos to be ready